you were watching ColdFusion TV
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
so they've finally done it the SpaceX
team have just successfully launched and
landed the Falcon Heavy rocket this is
the largest rocket in operation and
during the launch the atmosphere was
electric
the Falcon Heavy consists of 27 engines
with five million pounds of thrust
that's as much as eighteen Boeing 747s
in fact it's so much thrust that there's
no need to run the engines at max
capacity during the launch instead the
thrust is throttled and optimized
throughout the flight so here's the plan
for the test launch mission the Falcon
Heavy rocket would take off from Kennedy
Space Center and then releases payload
out into space
two of the rocket boosters would be
programmed to return back to Cape
Canaveral to be recycled while a third
booster which will be traveling much too
fast to me the Cape would be landing on
a floating platform 500 kilometers
offshore with the Boosters measuring 16
storeys in height it was a tall task the
Falcon Heavy is essentially three Falcon
nines strapped together with some
modifications carried out but it wasn't
as easy to get flying as it may first
seem
according to Elon at a press conference
post launch they had to be alterations
to the Boosters and the main core had to
be almost completely custom built
additional idea was just I thought you
know you stick on to two first stages of
side boosters how hard can it be it's
like way hard where to redesign the
center core completely this was due to
the changes and forces and hence
stresses and Dhirubhai the new setup
there was 10 million pounds of force in
some areas the challenge was so drastic
that the team considered abandoning the
project three times but it's a good
thing that they stuck with it because
now the Falcon Heavy is the largest and
most powerful rocket available capable
of carrying twice the payload of its
closest competitor the mission was
largely a success and the payload was
delivered without a hitch speaking of
the payload it was pretty interesting
it happened to be one of Ellen Musk's
original cherry red Tesla Roasters with
a mascot dubs star man he was looking
pretty chill wearing the SpaceX
spacesuit star man and his Tesla now
we'll be getting thrust into deep space
on its way to an elliptical orbit around
Mars for about a billion years
meanwhile the 16 story tall rocket
boosters returned down
in or inspiring fashion
[Applause]
Alden go exactly according to plan
though two of the three rockets required
to turn the main stage back to earth
failed causing the main stage rocket to
be lost it slammed into the ocean at
over 400 kilometres an hour
100 meters away from the floating barge
regardless the launch was hailed as a
success and is a huge step in the road
towards regular space launches as now
the price has been cut by four and a
half times for the equivalent competing
rocket United Launch Alliance as delta 4
heavy which is less powerful costs
around 400 million dollars and the
Falcon Heavy 90 million and this is
one-tenth the cost of NASA's planned
space launch system that's in
development to venture out to the Moon
and Mars the main cost savings here come
from the fact that the Falcon Heavy is a
reusable design one of the aims of the
mission was to collect vast amounts of
data in order to perfect launch
procedures the end goal was to make such
launches commonplace and as safe as
aircraft travel which is the safest has
ever been by the way
in the press conference Elin stated that
the Falcon Heavy opens up a new class of
payload and can send cargo all the way
to Pluto if we wanted no gravity sling
needed he states that this could
encourage other countries and companies
to do bigger and better he wants a new
space race but I think it's gonna open
up a sense of possibility I think it's
gonna encourage other companies and
countries to say hey if SpaceX which is
a commercial company can do this they
could go to some things can encourage
other countries and companies to raise
their sights and say hey could you're
bigger and better which is great we want
any space race Elon also did mention
that the bfr method is the way forward
but this Falcon Heavy launch gave him
more confidence in that project and as a
side note is kind of strange on videos
like this I often get people commenting
that scientific discovery is somehow a
zero-sum game they say why waste money
on something like this when you could be
spending their money eradicating cancer
it's a strange world view position but I
believe that engineers and scientists
are free to follow their passions and
can work on different things at once and
it's not to mention that progress in
space exploration
can have spin-off effects for example we
wouldn't have aircraft anti-icing
technology or the digital image sensor
in your smartphone or solar panels in
their current form if it weren't for
nasa's space program but in closing off
this video as I thought about the Falcon
Heavy launch it's just really insane
that this company was the result of a
private startup not some government
initiative and it was a very hard road
you know there are American heroes who
don't like this idea the alarm strong
gene cernan have both testified against
commercial spaceflight in the way that
you're developing it and I wonder what
you think of that I was very sad to see
that you know those guys are heroes of
mine so it's really tough no I wish they
would come and visit and see the
hardware that we're doing here
and I think that would change their life
they inspired you to do this didn't they
yes
and to see them casting stones in your
direction
[Music]
SpaceX was so close to failing when they
attempted to launch their first rocket
the Falcon 1
they failed three times and they had
just barely enough money for one more
try it turned out that the third failure
was caused by a two-second glitch in the
timing if that poor force hadn't worked
that would have been it we would have
not had the resources to the larger
faith and on September 28th 2008 on the
4th and final attempt SpaceX became the
first private company to launch a
liquid-fueled rocket that could reach
orbit
fast forward a decade later and they're
making history again and the future
looks at the very least exciting with
bigger plans on the horizon for the bfr
this whole story makes me smile and I
wish the SpaceX team more success in the
future
it's great innovation and I think it's
good for this generation to see things
like this anyway thanks for watching
this has been - go go you've been
watching cold fusion if you've just
stumbled across this channel feel free
to subscribe and of course I'll catch
you again soon for the next video which
hopefully it will be how big is Honda so
stay tuned cheers guys have a good one
[Music]